the creator of a blood testing company
has been convicted of fraud in the u.s
after duping investors and patients into
backing revolutionary technology that
she knew didn't work
theranos founder elizabeth holmes said
her company's labs could scan for
hundreds of diseases and health problems
by taking just a few drops of blood with
a finger prick test but the 37 year old
now faces up to 80 years in prison legal
experts though say she's unlikely to get
anything close to the maximum sentence
let's take a look now at how elizabeth
holmes created and subsequently
destroyed her company
elizabeth holmes dropped out of stanford
university in march 2004
soon after founding theranos its name
was a combination of therapy and
diagnosis
by september 2015 the company was worth
nine billion dollars homes who still
owned 50 of the company was named one of
the richest women in america
but
just a month later the wall street
journal claimed that theranoss's blood
testing technology was so flawed the
company was actually using equipment
made by other businesses to carry out
tests in its labs
in may 2016 theranos voided two years
worth of blood test results from its
testing devices
leading forbes magazine to lower its
valuation of the company from 9 billion
to 800 million dollars and homes net
worth from 4.5 billion dollars to zero
then in march 2018
holmes was charged with a fraud
following more than
700 million from investors by
exaggerating or making
false statements about the company's
technology business and financial
performance over a series of years
in september 2018 it was announced that
berenos would be dissolved then nearly
three years later in august 2021
following delays due to covid and holmes
pregnancy her trial began ending
in her conviction yesterday on two
counts of wire fraud and two counts of
conspiracy to commit
fraud well our business presenter ian
king is in our city studio for us uh
just reading that detail there in you
can really see just what a meteoric
rise and fall this was tell us more yes
that's right elizabeth holmes uh who
very very uh self-consciously modeled
herself on steve jobs the co-founder of
apple even down to wearing a black
turtleneck sweater she was a college
dropout left college at the age of 19
and founded theranose thereafter so
a a real success story in terms of
silicon valley she attracted a
glittering array of investors among them
betsy devos a former u.s education
secretary her family invested tens of
millions of dollars in the business
another investor was rupert murdoch the
billionaire media tycoon and another was
one of the heirs of stavros niarcos the
greek shipping tycoon all of those
people put money into the business and
indeed betsy devos was one of the
investors who was named in the
indictment and uh there was a veneer of
respectability provided for this company
uh theranose by the number of people
that were on its board they had no fear
than two former u.s secretaries of state
dr henry kissinger and george schultz
two very very distinguished u.s
diplomats both of them were on the board
of theranos and it was really an
investigation by the wall street journal
that brought the business to its knees
the journal
had ran a number of investigative
articles by a reporter called john
carrera who went on to write a very
successful award-winning book bad blood
about the crisis and it was that that
really got people questioning as to
whether all of the produce that theranos
was making were really cracked up to it
an interesting aspect to this case by
the way is the fact that there were also
uh indictments
on whether
patients were deceived not just
investors but patients and interestingly
enough the jurors found elizabeth holmes
not guilty on that it's been suggested
that's because there wasn't sufficient
evidence available for prosecutors to
make a conviction a deliberate jury get
a jury to find her guilty on that count
but nonetheless as you say potentially a
big prison sentence lies in store for
elizabeth holmes it could be quite a
while though before she's behind bars
the sentencing hearing may take up to
six months and there may even be a
retrial on some of the three counts that
elizabeth holmes the jurors couldn't
find uh they couldn't come up with a
verdict on that and that may in turn be
complicated by the fact that uh sonny
balvani who's the former chief operating
officer of theranos and miss holmes's
former lover well he's also facing
charges as well so that may complicate
any retrial now during the trial itself
elizabeth holmes accused sonny balvani
of uh mistreatment of her uh forcing her
to have sex against her will she
actually said that on the stand as well
and that's been termed the svengali
defense in legal circles and john
carrera the wall street journal
investigative reporter who blew the lid
on this whole story he actually tweeted
this morning the swengarly defense did
not work so there are a lot of twists
and turns yet to come in this company a
lot of lessons also for silicon valley
where of course you have this really
freewheeling culture vast sums of money
being plowed into tech startups not all
of them potentially all they're cracked
up to be